jessica kellgren-fozard thank you so
much for joining us on divided
and thanks to to to ruthanne who's
sitting over my shoulder here
interpreting for you using
sound supported english sse for this
interview
i'm jessica i'm a deaf youtuber and i
make
very fun videos twice a week ready
let's go wait first thing remove hearing
aid
we do various gay things
because you know everything we do is gay
yeah because we're gay where are you
going with us
you've been sent this video to explain
the disabled point of view on why the
strawberry
is a bad thing jessica for people who
don't know you
yes tell us a bit about yourself i make
videos that are about disability
awareness
chronic illness awareness uh also some
like fun
lgbt stuff with my wife and a lot of my
message is just about
taking bad things that have happened in
life and learning really positive
things from them and taking the
positives seeing how you can turn every
situation into a silver lining
tell me a little bit about about you and
your wife and and how you got and how
you got together
i've actually been on 70 first dates
fantastic i know
picky well you say becky um
it's kind of half and half in that it's
very much
that difficulty of hi this is who i am
i like like you like me wonderful by the
way i've got this this this and this
and this is what my life is like and
and that can be quite a lot did you get
that out in the first conversation that
you had
was that was that first date in a
milestone why am i going to waste my
time
you know i think if if you go on five
dates with someone obviously first of
all i have to tell them by the way i
can't really hear you very well you have
i lip read
you have to look at me don't put your
hand over your mouth let's not be in
dark situations
blah blah blah but if i waited till the
fifth date
to say by the way i also have these
other disabilities and sometimes i
paralyze myself and sometimes i have to
use a wheelchair and sometimes i have to
use
crutches and then they go oh uh
well i can't cope with that ever bye i'm
like well
was uh my one trip a week ruined great
i mean you smile you're smiling about
that but that must i mean over the
course of 70 days
there must have been times when that was
pretty exciting yeah but i think
more was just like well you're just not
the person for me yeah like
fine my person is still out there and
she very much was
when we first met on the first date um
i actually i also can't drink alcohol so
i would always do this thing where i
went
to every meeting first and i get like a
virgin margarita
just be like i'm cool i'd like to i'd
like to say i use the same technique but
that's clearly not true
but genuinely the cannot drink thing
freaks people out
way more than anything else really yes
it's so strong just because it's so
socially ingrained in it yeah
i always find that really weird that the
first thing
people like oh okay you're deaf yeah
cool okay so you got like chronic
fatigue and chronic pain yeah cool cool
wait you don't drink
no dexteres can't work okay well
so i was there with my little virgin
margarita and she came in
and i saw her and honestly felt that
kind of puzzle piece click into place
and was like oh hi
oh you're the one it is nice to to hear
stories like this because for you know
and you i will include sky and using
this sometimes the only stories that one
hears about disabled people involving
disabled people are sad one and it's
such a misrepresentation
and it's also very unfair i think that
we need to have
more dramas more news stories
more i want to see documentaries that
have disabled presenters
but the documentary is not about their
disability it's not about anything
medical
they're talking about art in the 14th
century
and just happen to be in a wheelchair or
just happens to be a deaf presenter
talking about picasso i don't know why
this is all art related
could be other things so i was glazing
over there
do you feel defined by other people
who look at you who hear your story and
who identify
mctd hnpp as as you first
and then the rest after well i
like the label disabled and i think that
it shouldn't be a label that i
should be afraid of wearing i think that
we shouldn't be using disabled like it's
a some kind of terrible bad word because
then what are we teaching
young people who are disabled and
they're growing up and they know that
that's them
but they're being told oh no that's a
that's a bad word we don't use that we
hush that we put that one away
it's like but that's part of me that's
part of who i am
it should be like you know what the word
disabled means to me it means that
you're a fighter
it means that you struggle every day
about because of something but you're
still here
you're still doing it and that's amazing
i worked for a local tv channel
and i got some sort of well i got some
online
hate about being not disabled enough not
allowed to call myself disabled because
i have
invisible disabilities i have two
genetic disabilities and then they lead
to living with chronic illness as well
i have if you want to know no please
i have a thing called hereditary
neuropathy with liability to pressure
palsies
and mixed connective tissue disorder
with associated postural orthostatic
tachycardia syndrome
we might we might use the abbreviations
here should we start with with
the first hnpp hereditary neuropathy
with liability
to pressure palsy i understand the words
but put them together
so explain that so what that means is
hereditary means it's inherited
i've got it from my father it's in my
genes i'm actually missing a gene
which makes me a cool mutant so
got some good powers just waiting for
the x-men to call me up any day now
and what that means is that the myelin
sheath that cuts your nerves it's sort
of like electrical wire
if you can imagine so it's got a plastic
coating on the outside
mine's got holes in it which means that
if i put
pressure on a nerve the nerve can either
swell and go through that hole or it can
fray underneath the hole
which means that it can then paralyze so
when i was 17 i paralyzed both of my
arms for a year and a half
because i had a crick in my neck i
paralyzed my legs
numerous times i've paralyzed my feet
and sometimes these can last for a very
long time
again like a year and a half or two
years and sometimes it's
very brief like a few days and also
affects the sensation so i can't like
feel the side of my face that type of
thing
and then mixed connective tissue
disorder which affects my
soft tissues so that's all my organs as
well as my ligaments
and together they're not great like
individually these things one of them
wouldn't
be wouldn't have such a big effect on my
life but unfortunately the way that they
work together is that
because i'm so likely to dislocate
things that then puts an awful lot of
pressure on my nerves
which makes the nerve condition worse so
take it so how do you then
live with these conditions on on on a
day-to-day basis
oh uh well i suppose you know you seem
very positive about it
well yeah it's just my life right
everyone's got a different life we all
have different
things that we have to cope with uh it's
just part of who i am i suppose
so there are certain things that i have
to be very conscious of
and aware of hot things cold things
because i can't
feel temperature changes i have to not
sit in one place for too long
things like that but then obviously
there are the bigger effects
the symptoms of those disabilities which
are the things that
really have the impact in my life so i
have chronic fatigue
because my body is always constantly
under a lot of strain and a lot of
pressure
which means that i am very
very tired an awful lot of the time
i mean that's not really fair to say
it's not just being tired it's that kind
of physical exhaustion after you've run
a marathon
where you can't think straight that's
what i have to deal with a lot of the
time
um and then i've got memory loss chronic
pain so i take a lot of painkillers to
try and
ease that off but it's still always
constantly there it's just at a kind of
lesser level it's like my body is no
longer screaming at me it's just sort of
yelling at a low level so so are are
these
are these videos then that that you
produce where you where you talk about
the disabilities and the conditions i
mean are they cathartic the most
positive and the most empowering thing
is that i can now share with other
people who are in the same situation
so i can build a community that's for me
what's really important
i in my life if you take away the
internet i'm incredibly isolated
i don't actually have the opportunity to
leave my house very much because i don't
have
that energy but the internet means that
i'm not isolated and i'm not alone and i
can just talk to
hundreds of thousands of other people
using my youtube channel
it feels wonderfully empowering as a
teenager i was on bed rest for two years
i had a lumbar puncture went wrong and i
lost all of the
fluid in my brain and i had to lie in a
dark room because
sound light and touch brought me
excruciating pain
so for two years just any so you yeah
sound light and touch caused you yeah to
the extent that i was lying in my
hospital bed and if someone came and
put slight pressure on the bottom of the
bed
i would feel that as extreme pain it was
as if someone had hit me over the head
with the sledgehammer
and it takes a very long time to build
back your spinal fluid so
yeah it took me two years alone in this
room pretty much
and now i don't have to be alone but
also at the time i didn't have
the wonderful social media that i have
now i didn't have the ability to just go
on instagram or
go on facebook and not be so alone tell
us a little bit
about what you've described as the soft
activism
so i think it's very important that to
have a whole range of activism
out there in the world i think it's
important to put on billboards
like some people are gay get over it
that's the kind of
quite out there activism i would say
it's very in your face and it's quite
confronting for people
but then not everyone is going to be
reached by that not everyone is going to
be able to
take the message from that i think it's
more important
for them to be able to watch a video
that they think is going to be about
baking and it is about baking but also
halfway through
like i get a bit faint and i have to sit
down and then my wife
comes and brings me a drink and then i
start up again
it's that kind of learning about other
people's lives
through something in a kind of
roundabout way so like you were saying
with a hair tutorial
it's doing my hair and then putting my
hearing aids in and normalizing hearing
aids
so that people don't see them as just oh
i have clicked on a video
to learn about hearing aids and you
don't see them any other time
do you think that that people are are
just not
exposed to enough people with
disabilities for them to be
more aware or do you think that people
shut themselves off too
the funny thing is one-fifth of the
population has a disability
which is a huge number right i think
that's the largest minority
however um i think due to recent scope
figures
is that half of the british public
do have no contact with anyone who has a
disability and feel like they have
nothing in common with them
and say oh i wouldn't be able to relate
to someone who has a disability
but that's that's ridiculous right so
many people
who are just left on the outskirts and
people think oh no i couldn't i couldn't
connect to them
why oh just because that person's in a
wheelchair doesn't mean they don't
support your favorite football team
and you can't chat about that how should
we then educate
the broader public about the the unseen
conditions well i think it's to do with
kindness
i don't think it's necessarily saying
you need to be educated about
invisible disabilities i think it's you
to be educated about kindness
you need to be able to when you see
someone parking in disabled space
and then getting out of their car and
walking to the shop you need the first
thought to not immediately be oh my god
are they lying
is that not really their badge do they
steal that from their grandma we're all
dealing with a range of
difficulties in our lives right we all
have some kind of baggage whether that
be
emotional physical mental and it's
i think there just needs to be a level
of understanding that everyone's in a
different situation
i guess what i do is i do talk about
disability and i talk about a range of
other things as well
but for me i don't feel like oh
disability is everything i make my life
about disability it doesn't feel like
that at all
it's just my life is though though a
danger in perhaps
not letting the situation progress
organically in fact
and in fact forcing it i think positive
discrimination
has a i don't think that's a great term
because again we're using discrimination
and it feels a bit like wait who's being
discriminated against here
and people just don't realize the
amazing things that people can bring to
society
it's often thought of as like disabled
people we'll lump them together
they are this group of dependents and
it's society's job to look after them
but that's not in any way true we don't
necessarily understand
that if we just allow this group of
people to be in our everyday lives
spreading the joy and wonder that they
can spread
and sharing their unique talents how
much we could benefit
isn't there quite a lot though for
disabled people to be to be angry about
these days in the way in which they've
been treated by successive government oh
yeah frankly
i mean i think definitely there's a lot
for all to be angry about
when it comes to the government yes for
sure i mean universal credit
leaving people a five-week wait before
they get money and the government just
says oh you just have to borrow
money in that time and go into debt
that's what we advise how is that
acceptable in no way is it acceptable
therefore that
this government to an extent has has
blood in its hands i hate the phrase but
you know what i'm driving at there that
the
actions of this government have led to
people's deaths of course and the real
reason for that is that nobody actually
asked disabled people
nobody's spoken talked about it why do
they have a panel
that has able-bodied people on it's fine
to have able-bodied people but it
shouldn't all be
focusing on that young boy or girl who
just accidentally
found your channel what is the one thing
that you would want them to take away
from the work that you've produced on
youtube
i think i'd want to take away kindness i
think i'd want them to take away that
in all situations with other people i'm
going to approach it with kindness
so just consider i think consider with
kindness
think about what might be going on in
people's lives behind the scenes